the cultural marxists have done with
other artists who appeal to
conservatives like Jason Aldan or the
producers of sound to Freedom forces on
the left are trying to cancel Oliver
Anthony through smears because of his
YouTube playlist now this is going to
backfire ours just as it has before
because we're on to their tiresome and
desperate game
now someone who is not tiresome and
desperate is the actor and comedian Rob
Schneider he's also the star of Woke Up
in America available exclusively right
now on foxnation.com it is hilarious Rob
well um I don't want to introduce you
with desperate you know desperate and
what is that is just horrible and
tedious no that's not what that's not
what you look first of all if I may
correct your little news program Laura
let me just talk about when Biden in
Hawaii with the um you know when they're
honoring the victims of the fire he was
not sleeping he was taking a prayer nap
praying for the victims obviously it's
very obvious he's praying for us you
could tell mid sleep you can he did that
every once in a while and first of all I
know people complain it's 113 billion
dollars for Ukraine and 700 per Maui
citizen well let me just tell you you've
been to Hawaii I've been to Hawaii we
now we know how inexpensive everything
is over there you have to ship
everything in you know 700 goes a long
way you can buy a water carton of milk
six eggs four eggs
one flip-flop you know it's it's gonna
help a lot
Rob when you see the reaction to this
you know kind of a hillbilly guy doing
this song Bare Bones production just
catches on it's like it's a cultural
moment
what's your reaction to how the left
responds to this yeah it's starting
digging up his YouTube playlist root for
the underdog and now it's like you know
you have a guy who came out of nowhere
and a guy that has nothing and that you
know and all of a sudden to try to
destroy him or try to take that down as
some kind of right wing it's an ugly hit
it really is an ugly place to come from
but that doesn't surprise me because I
do think like it's very interesting that
the the Democrats now seem to be the
censorship party the warmongering party
and the by Administration they want to
control uh you know how you cook what
car you drive now what AC what air
conditioning you're gonna have so uh I
mean I don't know what kind of lube you
can use but eventually why shouldn't
they control they censor you they try
they if you say something the tech
companies don't want you to say on on
social media you're out so why shouldn't
they try to control what you can hear
and listen to and what you get to watch
and what you get to enjoy and then if
and then if it's something outside of
what the liberal Intelligentsia wants
you to watch well then we're going to
have to undermine it or destroy it but
like you said it's not going to work I
think the people are going to watch what
they want to watch and I think you can
try to uh cajole people all you want but
at the end of the day if it speaks to
you that like this song does I mean that
people are gonna um they're gonna come
around because if it makes money because
that's the one thing that they won't
ignore in Hollywood if it makes money if
it makes money then they'll kind of come
around very quickly you'll see four or
five of those guys in the next couple of
months beards of red hair the whole deal
yeah well imagine if I mean if he had
had a different Anthem let's say for he
was singing about a transition of sorts
that would have been a moment it would
have been
late night talk shows right and it's
nice because the late night talk shows
you can actually take the jokes from
each of them and replace them that's the
thing that's so amazing to me so I I do
think um you're right though but people
have spoken and people are going to
watch what they want to watch the idea
that you can control everything is that
what they want to do is destroy
everything that they don't agree with
and start over in this imagined Utopia
that doesn't exist and you know how well
imagined Utopias work out just as
Chairman Mao or uh comrade Stalin so I
think it's going to fall flat hopefully
soon and but people are going to want to
watch what they want to watch and that's
going to wherever they can get it and I
hope that uh that people continue to
support independent artists who have a
voice and are saying something that
resonates with them well actress of
Jennifer Aniston um I don't know what
her politics is but she's pushing back
on cancel culture and she's saying I'm
so over cancel culture I probably just
got canceled by saying that I just don't
understand what it means is there no
Redemption I don't know I don't put
everybody in our Harvey Weinstein basket
Rob
um that was good to see from her I mean
she's probably politically liberal but
liberals used to be for free speech and
they certainly used to be for Redemption
well if you listen to Bill Maher Bill
Maher is on the same page he just didn't
realize that the traditional liberalism
hasn't changed for free speech gay
rights women's rights uh don't judge
somebody by the color of their skin what
happens now that makes you a right-wing
fascist because it doesn't go far enough
now so that that is the problem but I
think with um
with cancel culture if you sit down one
on one I sat down with Bill Maher and
talked to him you know besides his you
know he's got a little Trump syndrome
thing going on but he is he's a moderate
he can talk to him if you get in the
room that's why it's so important to
have dialogue on campus so instead of
just instead of you know demonizing
everybody he said let's talk if you have
a better idea I'm going to adjust my my
opinion my my the idea of a belief
system that's why the woke thing is a
religion because you if you out if you
dare oppose any of it or question it
you're a heretic and that's where the
canceling comes in I think James Lindsay
does a great job talking about that
Jeffrey Tucker you know so but I do
think if you can get one-on-one with
people and have conversations again
that's what's so good about the podcasts
is that you can have a long conversation
you know you can come on and then you
realize that we're not so far apart but
you know I will say those algorithms
push you in your own political Echo
Chambers because that they'll keep you
there as long as you can but I think
what Americans can talk to each other we
realize you know when there was that
flood that's like I say in my comedy
special when there's that flood in
Houston and be there the boats were
coming to rescue people on the rooftops
you know what they weren't saying are
you a Democrat or Republican up there
this is the Republican vote sorry yeah
the Democrat vote's coming soon good
luck with that it's a kayak it's better
for the environment
so hey Rob Rob the first guess on my
radio show and I first started hosting
radio and now I'm doing my podcast but
first goes guest on my radio show like
18 19 years ago Gavin Newsom and then
John Kerry
and I had Bono I mean this was a
different world right and we oh yeah we
had a great time we all could talk so
that's uh that's how far you can't I
don't know how well Gavin Newsom can
talk and he will never go on just go
please if anyone's watching this and
wants to see Gavin Newsom at his best
watch him with Adam Carolla and Adam
destroy him for five minutes because
when you really have to have ideas
behind what you're doing and Gavin hair
gel has single-handedly destroyed that
state with the super uh majority of
Democrats you don't want a one-party
system I mean just look what happened in
San Francisco and Los Angeles you cannot
defend that in any way you know so I
wish I I hope for people make better
choices in California vote for people at
least get two parties back that's all I
ask
all right Rob as I said during the break
you're you're looking like Robert Evans
and um you have a Robert Evans look
going on so come back anytime it's great
to have you on tonight all right all
right you take care of us uh hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else